women have a harder time with failure
and yet everybody who has succeeded will
tell you that there is no success
without failure along the way I don't
just race and I don't just work on cars
I you know I race and I like to cook and
I like to travel and I like to look
pretty and I like to get dressed up and
I like hair and makeup and I like all
those other things and if you're willing
to make all the trade-offs that you need
to make you can't have it all what's
that belief nation it's Evan my one word
is believe and I believe in you I
believe you have an amazing gift inside
you that I want to see exploded onto the
world this is a new series called
girlboss I'm obviously not a woman but I
do believe that you can support one
community without putting another
community down so my goal with this
series is to shine a light of excellence
on women entrepreneurs and hopefully
inspire a few more girls to believe in
themselves as well enjoy so let's kick
things off with rule number one plan
with Mel Robbins do you have any other
advice for women to take charge of their
futures plan it sounds so stupid
I mean sometimes giving advice is
embarrassing because it's so obvious but
I could sit here and and literally give
you the details of eleven different
famous studies that talk all about the
fact that people that take the time to
write out a plan and write down two or
three things that they're going to focus
on that they actually have between 30
and depending upon the studies 60%
they're more effective at getting it
done and one of the reasons why this is
more important than ever is because you
work in such a distracted work
environment right so if you're gonna do
something so let's just let's just give
everybody the assignment what are two
things that you're going to do this year
to raise your leadership game what are
you gonna do to be a contender and it
could be that you're going to adopt a
certain kind of mindset it could be that
they're going to stop taking notes and
meetings it could be that you're gonna
volunteer for certain assignments it
could be that you're going to take a
course that ramps up certain skills that
you know are a deficiency
you need to post that somewhere in your
work environment so that visually you
are reminded because you'll forget and
if you were to do just that pick two
things that are gonna amp up your
leadership game and post some sort of
visual cue you will be more likely to
change and you'll be more likely to be
more effective rule number two is don't
fear failure with Arianna Huffington
women have a harder time with failure
and yet everybody who has succeeded will
tell you that there is no success
without failure along the way and I know
in my own life I've had plenty of
failures but once you succeed people
forget about your failures so I think
successful people should talk more about
their failures especially to women
because women who have a sense of
perfectionism and wanting to get
everything right often refuse to take
risks because when you take a risk you
never know if it's going to succeed or
fail my mother fortunately brought me up
believing that as she put it failure is
not the opposite of success it's a
stepping stone to success rule number
three be who you are with Danica Patrick
so you said what makes you different
makes you great where does that advice
come from that you when you talk to
people well I mean I think that the most
obvious one really obviously is being a
girl um so when I was younger and like
living in England and kind of early teen
years I don't think I I didn't care that
I was a girl I just didn't want to make
it real obvious I mean I didn't want it
to stand out you know I didn't wear nail
polish because when I talk about the
racecar I didn't want guy I'm looking at
my hands and seeing pink fingernails you
know I didn't you know wear pink and
purple and make it really flashy and
obvious no hearts and bows and you know
just kind of wanted to blend in and
having my seven-year-old daughter
am I really parts and bows or didn't
want to wear her she's now rejecting
them but she was all in them so well you
know you go through these phase
where you feel comfortable and sometimes
you don't and I didn't really feel
comfortable making it obvious and so so
it really was I came back from England
when I was 19 and you know I I let
myself kind of go there to be a girl a
little bit and it really came from a
kind of racy photo shoot that I did that
it was more girly of me and it just all
of a sudden it stuff started happening
and people were contacting me and
sponsors and teams and it just but
nobody questioned what I could do you
know it wasn't like people didn't didn't
think I could race or their opinion
really changed on that maybe they had
opinion on what I did but it didn't
change the opportunity to be able to do
what I wanted to do it just really was
opening doors and it was allowing it you
know it was me being able to tap into
something that was part of my
personality I mean I think we were not
one-dimensional people we have all kinds
of different sides to us we're not you
know I don't just race and I don't just
work on cars I you know I race and I
like to cook and I like to travel and I
like to look pretty and I like to get
dressed up and I like hair and makeup
and I like all those other things so it
was kind of a way for me to it was an
extension of me and but it was
celebrated so it came to you as you
embraced who you were exactly so you
know sometimes I really feel that
whatever it is it's the most different
about you is probably the most important
and the most special and the most useful
rule number four be willing to make
sacrifices with Indra Nooyi on a
relative basis yes I've had it all okay
on a relative basis I'm very fortunate
to have a wonderful husband two great
kids a very tight-knit family and
awesome job with a great team but you
know to get here and to stay here I mean
lots of trade-offs lots of sacrifices
you know under the water a lot of
collateral damage but I think somehow
I've had the strength to power through
all of that can you have it all that's
the big question in this definition I
think if you have the right support
system if you have an understanding
spouse if you want to be married and if
you're willing to make all the
trade-offs that you need to make you
can't have it all but while you do all
that there will be heartache
there will be pain there would be some
collateral damage underneath the surface
I've got to live with it
rule number five fight with nina dobrev
and there's a lot been happening lately
in hollywood right with the whole times
up movement with the me - movement which
i think there's this cleansing that is
happening so it's almost perfect timing
with the weather and the purifying of
the air and i know you're involved in
the times up campaign a movement crisis
why did you get behind this what's it
about and what do you want people to
know about it over the top i think 200
fortune 500 companies there's no women
on any of their boards or if there is
it's it's one woman on each on each
board of every company and so of course
if there's any kind of harassment or
abuse it's hard to go up to your bosses
if none of them are women and none of
them understand your position it's all
it's just not fair so our goal is to get
more women on the boards of companies
that have influence to trickle down into
the other industries because it's not
just our industry our industry gets the
most press and the most notoriety and
and you hear our voice is the most but
there's women in agriculture there's
women in finance there's women
housekeepers and all kinds of different
women that are in that don't really have
the power or didn't feel like they had
the voice but now we're all kind of
coming together and speaking up for the
little guys the medium guys the big guys
it's just I was incredibly inspired by
it and it's been an awakening and I'm
really excited to move forward into this
new year and see I've already seen so
much change and I have wanted so much
more
what can people do or you know watching
all these you know actors and actresses
and they're just women of influence who
are promoting this what can women do is
it just post on a hashtag on now is it
what's the action steps that I mean
colorful you can't do anything unless
you know about something
Faye's has been all about education what
our education people that this is
happening and we need to do something
about it now that we know about it now
that has become become such a big
movement
I mean Oprah Winfrey did amazing the
most incredible speech how did she kind
of winged it I actually wrote that
speech in the car is what I heard but
there's no way I would love to that
would be great
he's amazing I think she should be the
next president but now that we have that
awareness I mean time's up isn't just
about the awareness like if you go on
the website there's so many things that
people can do there's a fun that we've
started on a legal side so that we can
have a bunch of lawyers basically look
in-house lawyers that are already paid
so that women in the agriculture
industry or in any industry across the
board have someone they can go to that's
already paid for so it's not about I
think a lot of people can't afford a
lawyer so if something happens they if
if the company has a lot more money in
power they won't want to press charges
because they feel small but in this case
this this fund will pay for these
lawyers so that everyone has
representation across the board in every
industry that's great and then there's
are more things that are gonna be
rolling out in the next couple of months
that we're doing what's the website for
it time's up com go time's up now com
gonna make it up yeah let's make sure so
I don't say the wrong thing we can just
Google times up I'm sure you'll find it
yeah that's great and rule number six
the last time before my bonus rule is
focus on you first with Jada Pinkett
Smith every day when I wake up in the
morning I go into meditation and I ask
for guidance from the powers intangible
powers and I get focused I think about
what is will of me today okay let me
check that off make handle that what
does Jane Day today
what does daddy need today and okay Jada
before the day is done you better make
sure that you take care of your
self and that's a new thing for me when
you and Jaden would first born I had
forgotten how to take care of myself
because you guys were my world you guys
were my everything you still are but I
have forgotten how to do that and at the
end of the day the one thing that I
always want to tell you well oh and the
reason why you always have to be in
communication especially with me your
family your grandmother your father your
brothers your friends the people who
love you you have to understand that
life is a journey communication creates
partnerships hmm okay that we are here
to assist you that we can't we can't
make your life for you and we can't help
you with the things that we don't know
and that you always have to remember to
take care of you first and foremost
because when you stop taking care of
yourself you get out of balance and you
really forget how to take care of others
and I think that we've been taught that
taking care of yourself as a problem and
I'm telling you something about being a
mother and some of the messaging that we
get in this country about being a mother
that you have to completely sacrifice
everything mm-hmm you have to completely
sacrifice every single thing and I think
that what the the ream essage in that we
as mothers need to have and gravitate to
is that you have to take care of
yourself in order to have the alignment
and the power to take care of others at
the capacity that we do because it fills
the well what what I believe that I do
takes so much energy so much work from
heart spirit and creativity that I had
to be responsible enough to take care of
me because you know what happens
imbalance comes you know what happens I
look to you will and I say willow you've
got to do this because if you don't you
you become I start looking towards you I
start making you responsible for my
happiness and a lot of times you know we
do we look to our men we look to our
husbands and our boyfriends and we go
you I've given all this up for you and
you've got to make this right by me and
you're supposed to make me happy because
we've lost our way on how to make
ourselves happy we lost our way so what
I had to do and what I had to learn was
how to get more balance in over the
years each year each day I get more and
more and more and more imbalance more
and more and more alignment and you know
what I get more and more happy and the
very thing that I thought would make you
unhappy or make Jaden and happier make
daddy unhappy actually is fulfilling for
you guys as well even though you might
it might not be a tangible reason but
the more happy I am in the more
fulfilled I am it works for the family
and when I'm not it doesn't it's really
that simple
now I've got a very special bonus clip
with Warren Buffett and his views on
women in the workplace but before that I
want you to make a commitment of the day
what did you learn from this video that
you were going to practically apply
somehow in your life or in your business
leave it down in the comments below I'm
really curious to find out thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever you're one where
it is
much love I'll see you soon and enjoy
the bonus clip
men should realize that you know this
isn't well if they had if they had male
workers and those workers could
accomplish more if they had more
education or whatever it might be they
jump on that in a second and to take
half the people and and and and and not
recognize that they have just as much
potential as the others and and use them
is a big mistake but it's for both it's
for women to throw away the funhouse
mirror and start seeing themselves in a
real mirror and I think many a great
many do that that has changed a good bit
over the years but I don't there's room
to go if you look at the fortune 500
companies less than 20 have female CEOs
less than 20 it is corporate America
losing out big time well it's a mistake
not to use all the talent we have one
woman at Berkshire Hathaway that is now
chairman of foreign companies and but
that's all new and and she's doing a
terrific job and it comes slowly and
partly that's just there's just a
mindset that's different at Berkshire we
have 13 directors the six over 80 are
all men the six under 60 or half women
and a Half Men I mean that they're the
future the most important work ever if
you have to think of one word that's
most important to you or that sums you
Apple that would be to like a little
beacon they believe nation if you want
to know what the most important one word
is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details
[Music]